three members of congress
have said biden should be removed from
office using the 25th amendment of
course he should you only have to look
at the stumbling mumbling bumbling
performances we've had to endure the
last few weeks to see that he is clearly
incapable of carrying out his duties
properly he thinks he went to the tree
of life synagogue after the mass
shooting there but it turns out it was a
phone call a year later they have to
tell him where he is to wipe things off
his face which reporters to call on if
he can't run his own press conferences
how's he supposed to run the country
the people around by know how bad it is
but the last thing they'll ever do is
invoke the 25th amendment they love this
setup a weak puppet who signs whatever
they put in front of him perfect
that's the whole point of biden
as the silicon valley saying goes
biden's mental incapacity isn't a bug
it's a feature it is why he's there
46 members of congress think biden
should resign and of course he should
anyone with a slightest decency or
responsibility if they'd done this much
damage to the reputation and authority
of the country would have resigned by
now but we know biden won't he's a vain
self-inflating machine politician who's
been plotting and scheming to get this
job his entire adult life no joke as
biden would say in the mid 1960s
when he was in his early twenties
the first time he met the parents of his
first wife they asked him what he wanted
to be and he said president
president of what they asked
the united states he replied what kind
of person talks like that thinks like
that a sociopath with narcissistic
personality disorder that's who someone
like that literally has no shame biden's
not going to resign
so how will there be accountability
for the needless deaths the nauseating
debacle the national disgrace
of biden's afghanistan disaster
mitch mcconnell says the midterms
what is he talking about
biden's not on the ballot in the
midterms yes biden's border crisis his
crime surge his economic incompetence
and disastrous handling of the pandemic
that'll all be part of the calculation
voters make in 2022 but so will their
views on their local candidate issues in
their district
biden is responsible for the biggest
foreign policy catastrophe
in american history and it wasn't just a
mistake
it wasn't just a policy that went wrong
it was cold
calculated cruelty
deliberately entered into for political
reasons against the advice of the people
on the ground you can't just throw it in
the mix alongside rising inflation and
health care costs
if a president can do this much damage
to the country can be this derelict in
his duty can cause the death
of 13 american service men and women and
countless others without censure or
rebuke without any direct consequences
what does that say about the health of
our democracy people say oh well you can
vote against him in 2024 as someone
might put it come on man who thinks
biden will be in any fit state to run
again the idea
that he just slinks out of the white
house without any sanction any
accountability for what he's done is
unconscionable and unacceptable
so
we're left with only one option
biden's behavior demands it and the
circumstances require it biden must be
impeached
and eleven members of congress have
already reached that conclusion we know
the threshold high crimes and
misdemeanors
there is no question none
that biden's behavior rises to that
level
here's how
13 members of the united states military
hundreds of civilians afghans and others
are now known to have died outside the
gates of kabul airport from an isis-k
suicide bomber all these deaths were
preventable and would have been
prevented if not for the specific
actions of the president
he said his military advisors told him
to abandon bagram that's not true
that our task was to protect the embassy
in order for the embassy personnel to
continue to function with their consul
services and all that
if we were to keep both barbarum and the
embassy going
that would be a significant number of
military forces that would have exceeded
what we had or stayed the same or
exceeded what we had so he had to
collapse one or the other
and a decision was made
it was biden's decisions that gave the
generals no choice but to abandon bagram
he said no one predicted the chaos
the intelligence committee did not say
back in june or july that in fact this
was going to collapse like it did
that's not true
a state department dissent member from
july read by secretary blinken and
communicated to biden is evidence
that the president was warned of the
taliban taking over if the august 31st
deadline was kept but biden insisted on
keeping it anyway
we now know from that leaked phone call
with exiled afghan president ashraf
ghani that he told biden at the end of
july how close things were to collapse
biden ignored that too
and the single most damning piece of
evidence
we now know
that even after their rapid advance the
taliban offered to allow the us to
control all of kabul not just the
airport
biden keeps saying there was no
alternative that is simply not true
there was an alternative and he rejected
it
as a direct result of these decisions
countless americans have been left
stranded behind enemy lines biden
promised not to leave until all
americans were out
if there's american citizens left we're
going to stay to get them all out
that was august the 18th and look where
we are today
we're hopeful that in the coming days
the qataris will be able to resume air
service out of kabul and if they do
we're obviously going to look to see if
americans can be part of those flights
yeah we hope maybe some other country
can get them out we'll look to see
because you know what we're moving on we
don't actually give a crap about the
american citizens we swore an oath to
protect we don't give a crap about a
direct and unequivocal promise the
president of the united states made just
days ago
all we care about is some demented pr
scam to try and give biden a sick
mission accomplished moment on september
the 11th
they keep saying they'll help get
americans out
an american in afghanistan tells us that
they want to stay for now
and then in a week
or a month or a year they reach out and
say i've changed my mind
we will help them leave
literally the day after he said that his
own department
issued a travel advisory telling
americans to make arrangements to leave
that quote do not rely on u.s government
assistance
the president of the united states has
knowingly deliberately left hundreds
probably many more of his own citizens
in the hands of a murderous band of
terrorists he talks about their
assurances
the taliban has made public commitments
broadcast on television
and radio across afghanistan
unsafe passage for anyone wanting to
leave including those who worked
alongside americans
public commitments yells biden
here's what the taliban's public
commitments are worth from the new york
times quote
human rights watch established that 44
people
were taken from their homes and executed
in july in the town of spinpoldak all 44
had received amnesty letters from the
taliban
the taliban sent them letters of amnesty
and then they killed them
that's how biden intends to protect the
lives of the americans he left behind
the most sacred promise of the u.s
military is leave no one behind
biden left hundreds maybe thousands
behind if a commander in the military
did this they would face a court martial
compounding his crimes far from ending
the forever war as biden pathetically
tries to claim he's just restarted it
just listen to this devastating
assessment from leon panetta who served
with biden as defence secretary and cia
chief
i don't think there's any question that
our national security is threatened
by what has happened
there is no question
that they will provide a safe haven for
al qaeda
and for isis and for other terrorists to
be able to reorganize uh strengthen
themselves again
and potentially use afghanistan as a
base for attacking
not just the united states but other
countries as well
biden caused the death of 13 service
members he has deliberately left
hundreds of known identifiable americans
in the hands of the enemy he has
knowingly created a new safe haven for
terrorists to attack america when an
alternative
that would have protected america and
protected americans was available but
rejected
if all that isn't impeachable i don't
know what is
this must be a litmus test for
republicans
biden promised competence but instead
brought chaos he promised compassion but
gave us cruelty he has betrayed our
allies broken his sacred trust brought
shame and humiliation on the presidency
and this great country
but our contempt for this utterly
discredited despicable man is not enough
he must be held accountable
biden must be impeached
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else